[Music]
the world health organization says
vaccine hesitancy is among the top 10
threats to global health
skeptics around the world have taken to
the streets to protest against covert 19
jabs
half the french are hesitant about
getting the shot
in germany it's a quarter of the
population
but experts agree will only beat the
virus with vaccines
well despite all the skepticism the
bigger problem has been getting enough
doses
but not in serbia it has such a vast
surplus that they had been inoculating
non-residents
still the abundance of vaccine doesn't
help when many people just don't want it
dw's funny facial reports it is the next
person in line's turn
about 4 000 doses are being administered
here today
at the biggest covet vaccination center
in serbia
the country has procured some 15 million
vaccines
for a population of seven million
serbia has more vaccines on offer than
serbians who want them in fact there's a
surplus of
russian of chinese and a
variety of other vaccines so the country
had been inviting
foreigners to take the jabs the emphasis
is on
head on the 9th of april the government
decided to suspend the vaccination of
foreigners
onto further notice about 30 000
had received a vaccine so far a lot of
foreigners
came but now it's impossible because of
the permission of the government so
they need to be a resident here or get
married here or something like that
for for now the announcement came after
serbia's infection rates began rising
again
the government had apparently realized
it needed to convince more of its own
citizens
to get a jab first at least 23 people in
serbia believes to some extent in
conspiracy
theories that claim vaccines are unsafe
you will see everyone who got the
vaccine will soon die
i think the vaccine is not safe enough
and that's why i don't want to get it
and that skepticism is also apparent on
belgrade streets
restaurants are full open and almost no
one is wearing a mask
epidemiologist soren radovanovic says
the government focused
too much on positive news about
procuring vaccines
while not doing enough to actually stem
the spread
of the virus we have a populist
government and our leader was
fond of demonstrating that is he is more
able than
anyone else any other leader to provide
what is needed and he ignored the fact
that
it was necessary to educate people
so far about 1.2 million people have
been fully vaccinated in serbia
according to official numbers a high
percentage by comparison
with other countries in europe but far
from enough to end serbia's pandemic
in an effort to increase immunization
among serbians
the government has now started focusing
on its own citizens
instead of foreigners if you could
understand serbian
you would be able to read the message on
the side of this local bus
it says get vaccinated
let's talk about vaccine skepticism with
renee najera college of physicians of
philadelphia
the fact we have a vaccine is a blessing
why then all the non-believers
why the non-believers that's a really
good question right i guess it's part of
human nature
to question things around us uh
to see risk in other people and assume
that it's the same risk for us and so
you know you're going to have a spectrum
of people who absolutely believe in the
science absolutely believe in vaccines
and then you're going to have a
the other end people who will not get a
vaccine no matter what you you
tell them how you explain to them
because they have this perceived risk of
it
no matter what they see i mean it's
great to question things i'm a
journalist i have to do it every day
but vaccine skepticism is as old as the
vaccine itself
has there been or was there some sort of
specific historical
incident that would justify the
skepticism
not not one specific uh there's been
several
ones throughout history right because uh
you know the vaccine
science has has been advancing for the
last 200 years and
along the way there have been incidents
that may or may not justify some of
their feelings
uh the most uh the most recent one was
uh
unexplained phenomena with the h1n1
vaccine
in which people um had narcolepsy and we
know that that happens to people who are
predisposed to narcolepsy who are
exposed to a viral
disease and so whether or not they would
have gotten it from the vaccine or from
actually getting flu
you know that that could happen um in in
the 1950s there was the cutter incident
here in the us with the polio vaccine
where a
laboratory failed to properly kill the
polio virus and ended up causing about
200 cases of paralysis from polio on
what should have been an otherwise
safe vaccine so yes along the way
there's been incidents that have been
amplified if you will
by the anti-vaccine movement as
something that happens very very often
when in fact it's actually very rare
explain to our viewers how
anti-semitic conspiracy theories also
play a role in the anti-vaxx movement
yeah so you know it's not just
anti-semitic but anti-minority
anti-anybody who is marginalized or
excluded and so
um you know throughout history jewish
people have been persecuted and they
have been the minority an ethnic
minority a religious minority and so
when it comes time to find somebody
who's guilty for whatever ails a society
in this case with with vaccine adverse
vaccine reactions then they turn
to to those those conspiracy theories um
in more modern times we have conspiracy
theories about
jewish people controlling bio bio um
security
or controlling pharmaceutical companies
and then wanting to just make money
right that's one of the tropes of
anti-semitism
and and not not going um not caring if
you will
about children getting hurt from the
vaccine so it's a combination of
historical factors of persecution of
these kinds of groups
um combined with conspiracy theories and
now in modern day
social media where one a small lie
can spread and become very very big
can you also explain why in some
countries it's the ethnic minorities
that are especially skeptical
about vaccines yeah because you know
you have uh the colonizers right the the
western european powers england spain uh
spain and the case of latin america
england in the case of north america
who have colonized uh ethnic minority
groups
in in foreign countries and in doing so
have abused
houston abuse uh in the united states we
have the original sin of slavery
and so you have a history of hundreds
and hundreds of years of the
authorities the government the the the
dominant uh
political force or dominant people
abusing uh
the ethnic minorities and so they see
anything that comes their way
as a mandate as something that they they
must do
uh for whatever reason they see it as
yet another imposition on them by this
colonial power or this uh abusive um
enslaving power and so they they get
skeptical and in many cases
there are some small instances in
that that justify it so for example um
in the united states puerto rico they
had a they have an island there vieques
beautiful island that was
bombarded by the u.s navy for years um
and and
a lot of the people from puerto rico are
skeptical of the us government
because of that and other abuses that
took place on their own
island and so now when they are being
told by the same government that did
that to them to get a vaccine
they're highly skeptical so renee give
me the hard sell as a scientist
how would you convince an anti-vaxxer
we found through science through
research through surveys and through
focus groups that the best way to get at
somebody is by having one of their peers
not somebody who's superior to them not
somebody who's inferior not somebody
who's smarter more educated richer
whatever
somebody who is their peer at their
level explain to them the benefits of
vaccination explain to them
the side effects if any of getting a
vaccine and we've seen it with the covet
19 vaccine where we had a lot of
skeptical people at first
who are now turning turning around and
wanting the vaccine after seeing their
peers their neighbors or friends
getting the vaccine having a little bit
of a side effect afterward you know a
little bit of a flu-like
illness for a day or so and getting much
better and then also seeing that they
the the people who are vaccinated are
not becoming sick and they're not
becoming parts of outbreaks
when they see that from their peers
especially they have changed their minds
and so that is
one of the science and evidence-proven
ways to get at somebody who is skeptical
about vaccination
i don't mind at all if they wait means i
get in line quicker
renee najira college of physicians of
philadelphia thanks for being on the
show today
thank you for having me and for the last
time this week here's our science
correspondent derek williams
with another viewer question about
backseats
i was vaccinated a few days ago my arm
didn't hurt and i didn't have any side
effects
is that normal i talked a lot here about
vaccine side effects so it's great to
hear from someone
who had none because that's actually
really
common um i haven't been vaccinated yet
but among
friends and family who have i'd say
roughly
half told me they didn't notice a thing
afterwards although the statistics will
vary
from from vaccine to vaccine it looks
like
for most of them at least a third of all
recipients don't report even the mildest
of side effects like like injection site
pain or
or a little bit of swelling there's no
way
to predict in advance exactly how you'll
react
but but experts say two factors
clearly increase the likelihood that
you'll feel some kind of discomfort
after getting a shot the first
is your sex recent cdc
data shows that around 4 out of 5
reports of covid vaccine side effects
have come
from women which doesn't come as a
surprise really since that's also been
observed in the past
with many other types of vaccine a
number of
of biological and and possibly even
social reasons
uh seem to contribute to to that
phenomenon
the second factor that plays a role is
your age
uh younger people are a lot more likely
to report
side effects than those over 55 which is
another result backed up by experience
with past vaccines the theory there
is that's because the immune response in
general
declines with age so in a nutshell
having few or no side effects after
being vaccinated
isn't particularly rare and apparently
even less so if you're like me a man
who's no longer a spring chicken
[Music]
mother of mine i could get mine next
week thanks for watching stay safe
[Music]
you